La tortuga y la liebre están compitiendo
para ver quien puede correr 100 pies
en la  menor cantidad de tiempo.
Sus posiciones en pies,
como función del tiempo en segundos,
"T" de "t" y "H" de "t" respectivamente,
están graficadas abajo.
Entonces, "T" de "t" es la posición de la tortuga
en función del tiempo y está en pies
y "H" de "t" es la posición de la liebre.
¿Cuál es el significado de la razón de cambio
de "T" de "t" en el intervalo
en donde "t" es mayor que 0 y menor que 20?
Así que, "T" de "t", estamos diciendo
que la tortuga está aquí,
está es la función "T" de "t",
esta línea azul
y parece que se está moviendo
a una razón de cambio constante.
La pendiente de esta línea es constante,
así que veamos cual es esta razón de cambio.
Si empezamos,
podemos empezar desde la posición de inicio,
cuando pasa un segundo,
cada división en eje horizontal
es un segundo, es,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
así que cada vez que pasa un segundo
parece,
parece que...
y tenemos que ser muy cuidadosos aquí.
Al principio podemos decir,
¡Oh! puede que haya avanzado un pie,
tenemos que ser cuidadosos,
sobre qué es lo que estas divisiones representan.
Vemos que estas divisiones representan
5,
10,
15,
20,
25 pies,
así que cada vez que pasa un segundo,
él se mueve adelante por 5 pies,
pasa otro segundo
y se mueve adelante otros 5 pies.
Entonces parece que la tortuga,
la tortuga,
la razón de la tortuga,
la razón
de la tortuga,
la razón de la distancia con respecto al tiempo,
es 5
pies
por cada segundo.
Entonces, veamos cuál de nuestras opciones
empata con eso,
y eso debe ser en el intervalo entero.
El intervalo comienza aquí en 0
y el 20 está aquí.
Y parece que tiene una razón constante,
tiene una pendiente constante
con la misma inclinación de la línea todo el tiempo,
todo el camino
hasta que "t"es igual a 20.
Entonces la primera opción, es que la tortuga camina
a 5 pies por segundo todo el tiempo,
y esto parece correcto,
ya que la razón de la tortuga,
es igual a 5 pies por segundo de manera constante.
Este camina puede ser entendible,
5 pies por segundo es una buena velocidad,
especialmente para una tortuga.
Así que iremos por ésta.
También vamos a revisar las otras por diversión,
para ver que tan ciertas son
o cómo pueden ser aplicadas a este problema.
La liebre deja de moverse de después de 5 segundos, así que veamos.
Este es el tiempo 0, aquí son 5 segundos,
si buscamos,
si buscamos la posición de la liebre
después de 5 segundos,
entonces después de 5 segundos,
después de que el tiempo es igual a 5 segundos,
de hecho se ve cómo la
posición de la liebre,
la liebre está solo sentada ahí, en los 90 pies,
en la línea que marca los 90 pies,
y no hay ningún movimiento.
La razón de cambio de la posición con respecto
al tiempo para la liebre en esta posición es 0,
así que esto es correcto,
solamente que no aplica a la pregunta,
no es el significado de la razón de cambio de "T" de "t"
en este intervalo, esto es "H" de "t".
La liebre corre a una velocidad
de 18 pies por segundo, por los primeros 5 segundos.
Veamos si esto es cierto.
Por los primeros 5 segundos,
estos son 5 segundos pasando,
la liebre es capaz de recorrer una distancia...
la liebre es capaz de recorrer
una distancia de 90 pies.
Entonces la liebre es capaz de recorrer
90 pies en 5 segundos.
Para los primeros 5 segundos...
primeros
segundos,
la liebre,
la razón
de la liebre es
90 pies
podemos decir,
que la razón de cambio promedio es 90 pies
en 5 segundos
y 90 dividido entre 5 es igual a
18 pies por segundo.
Así que una vez más este tercer enunciado es cierto, solamente que no aplica para "T" de "t".
No está haciendo referencia a la pregunta.
Y la cuarta opción es, la libre gana la carrera.
Ahora, ganar la carrera es llegar a los 100 pies
en la menor cantidad de tiempo.
Aquí son los 100 pies, así que veamos.
Parece que solo la tortuga llega a este punto,
a los 20 segundos la tortuga llega a la marca
de los 100 pies,
la liebre se queda dando vueltas
o comiendo una manzana o algo a los 90 pies,
así que esto es en realidad falso,
la tortuga gana la carrera,
entonces definitivamente escogemos la primera opción.